et pour en parler nous accueillons
eugène berg ancien ambassadeur de france
auteur de la russie pour les nuls
bonsoir à vos côtés gros choc à vos
côtés frédéric sinclair éditorialiste
ancien conseiller diplomatique de
dominique de villepin un bon soir alors
messieurs on le disait un réception en
grande pompe pour l'opposante
biélorusses dans un contexte
diplomatique particulier entre la russie
et l'europe on pense notamment à la
sphère navalni alors ce contexte
particulier svetlana à tirano sky à 100
certaines comme un ressort finalement à
schönberg
écoutez elle a été elle a été une grande
surprise
d'abord parce que le cash and co ne
faisait pas confiance aux femmes
finalement il n'a pas vu son aura et
qu'elle pouvait lui être lui rassemblé à
son devoir
bon on va pas parler du nom de voix
c'est controversé c'est pas toujours
très claires et finalement elle et elle
s'est comportée on dit que c'est une
novice elle s'est comportée avec une
habilité assez forte
une certaine maturité pour quelqu'un qui
n'avait jamais fait politique et qui s'y
abriter des à son époux qui lui
incarcéré alors par exemple elle a
toujours dit que elle reste une femme
une mère et qu'elle est là pour suppléer
journée alors là j'ai écouté son
discours qui est très bref en anglais
elle est interprète d'anglais elle a dit
deux choses à mon sens qu'ils sont un
peu nouvelle les promeneurs la première
c'est qu'il faut exercer les sanctions
contre loukachenko
les auditeurs seront se souviendront
certainement qu'une quarantaine de
personnalités biélorusses ont déjà été
sanctionnés mais pas le président là la
demande et que des pressions soient
faites sur le président lui même et pour
montrer son sens de l'opportunité sont
disons la manière dont elle a déjà les
elle sait parler aux médias l'a reçu un
mur de berre
un élaphe est évidemment le parallèle
après le mur de berlin je suis sûr que
le mur qui est dans mon pays va aussi
s'abattre et donc appel du pied de
l'europe mais elle a pas parlé de la
médiation
elle en parlera peut-être demain elle
attend une médiation
elles attendent à une médiation du
président emmanuel macron avec le sp1 là
aussi c'est pas tout à fait clair notre
président dit qui a l'aval de vladimir
poutine
est ce que c'est vraiment acté à qui est
ce qu'elle a demandé
il faudra le voir dans les minutes ou
dans les heures qui vont venir est ce
qu'elles demandaient une médiation
également de angela merkel qui est quand
même président l'union européenne est ce
que c'est une médiation française une
médiation franco-allemande européenne là
aussi faudra éclaircir parce que
certainement l'ensemble des 27 seront
pas à 100% sur une ligne dure une ligne
disons de confrontation mais plutôt une
ligne de diète de continuer le dialogue
et de pousser à la médiation et de
pousser finalement une sortie aussi
j'allais dire aussi calme si on peut
parler de calme parce que comme des
violences des manifestations des
arrestations
voilà un petit peu le sens de ce message
qui est qui qui a été très bref en
quelque sorte
frédéric saint clair on connaît aussi de
tensions autour du projet de gazoduc
nord stream ii est ce que ce dossier
s'imbriquent également avec celui de la
biélorussie dans les intérêts dans les
intérêts européens
alors oui vous parlez d'intéresser c'est
le sait le mot on est dans un dans un
rapport de puissance tout dans les tous
dans les relations internationales
finalement ses relations internationales
elle simplifie parfois un petit peu là
la mécanique politique parce que le la
recherche d'intérêts politiques pour le
peuple ou économiques pour eux pour le
peuple est clairement assumé bien
souvent dans la politique nationale on
on nous fait entrer diverses notions
idéologique pour la politique
internationale c'est souvent plus clair
dans le cas qui nous occupe là la
question qu'il faut se poser c'est quels
sont les intérêts des biélorusses
quels sont les intérêts des français et
des allemands et ensuite quel est
l'intérêt de vladimir poutine
si tous les intérêts comme jane berg
vient le préciser si tous les intérêts
convergent à la fois à l'ouest de la
biélorussie et à l'est
il est possible il est possible qu'on
puisse trouver un compromis une voie de
sortie qui va contraindre politiquement
fortement le président loukachenko
si ce n'est pas le cas et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui ce n'est pas le cas pour
des raisons assez simple c'est que la la
la biélorussie est une zone tampon entre
l'actuelle union européenne et la russie
et bertrand badie a beau avoir écrit la
fin des territoires je crois que on
n'assiste pas encore la fin des
territoires et que ces territoires ont
une importance et qu'aujourd'hui pour la
russie gardez la biélorussie dans son
giron
ça reste un enjeu majeur alors vous avez
mentionné north stream effectivement il
ya des enjeux énergétiques mais
simplement des enjeux aussi économique à
vous rappeler que en 2010 une union
douanière a été mise en place entre la
biélorussie la russie et le kazakhstan
si ma mémoire est bonne donc il ya des
enjeux économiques
une union douanière c'est quand même un
projet économique fort donc où se trouve
finalement la ligne de partage entre les
intérêts de vladimir poutine et ceux de
l'union européenne représentée par le
franco allemand alors justement le jeune
berck est l'intérêt partage paris et
berlin en étant à la manoeuvre dans le
dossier biélorusse c'est quoi des
intérêts financiers des intérêts d'
influence de territoire expliquer nos
jeunes
non je pense que c'est nina neil hall
c'est simplement la france et
l'allemagne
j'irai pas que s'arrogent le droit de
parler au nom des européens au nom de la
famille européenne
je pense que ils veulent jouer un rôle
parce que c'est comme de puissance bon
l'allemagne est pas loin des frontières
vous savez la famille européenne et est
quand même j'irai un peu divisé et il
faut apaiser les craintes
bon je vais pas faire une typologie de
toutes les positions l'intérieur il est
évident que les pays baltes la pologne
sont très offensives je vais pas refaire
l'histoire
une partie des territoires biélorusses
ont été dans le grand duché ponot
lituanien une partie du territoire de la
pologne est passée la biélorussie après
et c'est pas pour rien que en 89 quand
il y avait un front national en
biélorussie c'est le sache ou 10 le
mouvement lituanien d'indépendance donc
tout ça n'est pas mort évidemment le
disons que pour un lecteur français
moyen c'est loin c'est un peu compliqué
mais cette histoire est là c'est bien la
pologne et la lituanie qui accueille
déjà depuis longtemps les opposants
donne des bourses aux étudiants
donc là il ya une manifestation un
combat géopolitique qui dure depuis des
décennies des siècles qui continue et
voilà je ne dirais pas qu'ils mettent
systématiquement l'huile sur le feu mais
ils le font alors la france et
l'allemagne sont bon j'irai pas qu'ils
veulent apaiser mais réduire un peu les
tensions brider un petit peu la pologne
lituanie parce qu'ils ont besoin d'elle
ils peuvent pas ils peuvent pas
s'opposer on a besoin finalement puisque
l'europe ne marche que par les compromis
permanent donc on doit un petit peu les
dans leur sens pour les apaiser pour les
brive est en quelque sorte parce que là
aussi le président mac ronfle va dessus
pour lui rendre hommage
il est allé il a effectivement
rencontrer l'opposante
c'est un assistanat ou pas facile à
prononcer cyrano ce qu il a il a dit que
je suis toujours pour maintenir une
architecture de paix et de sécurité avec
la russie donc quelle que soit
l'évolution
on de la biélorussie il faut espérer
qu'il y aura pas d'intervention
extérieure qu'on va pas tirer sur les
foules sertir la violence pour l'instant
les contenus il ya comme la guerre au
karabakh
c'est un palier mais il ya d'autres
violences donc le monde est loin d'être
calme hein on le voit donc et je crois
que la france et l'allemagne jouent ce
rôle pour préserver cette architecture
de paix de sécurité pour maintenir le
dialogue car s'il ya pas de dialogue sur
la confrontation et je crois qu'on a
suffisamment à faire dans doute reçoit
la planète pour en ajouter une voie là
le grand message alors qu'il faut
comprendre qu alors évolutive on va y
revenir aux relations franco russes
aujourd'hui mais avant frédéric sinclair
je vous pose la la mais la même question
qu'est ce que l'on voit à l'oeuvre du
côté de paris et berlin est ce que c'est
la défaite la défense d'intérêts
financiers ou alors d'intérêt d'un
finances de territoire il y a
globalement une défense d'un modèle
politique on pourrait presque dire
idéologique un rapport à la la façon à
la puissance qui est prônée par
l'ensemble de l'occident europe etats
unis compris qui est le modèle de la
démocratie libérale et face à cela on a
une division au sein même de l'europe
c'est-à-dire ce modèle de la démocratie
libérale est contesté au sein même de
l'europe et aux frontières de l'europe
est ce qu'on est en train de voir
émerger c'est un autre modèle politique
qui n'est pas libérale qui n'est pas
complètement illibérale non plus parce
qu'on a beau dire ce qu'on veut mais la
hongrie n'est pas non plus un exemple du
libéralisme ans n'est pas en iran ou en
chine et donc il ya un autre modèle
politique un autre projet politique
démocratique qui est en train d'émerger
emmanuel macron et angela merkel sont
opposés à ce modèle là ensuite se
greffent là-dessus ce que clément bonne
donc été le conseiller de d'emmanuel
macouin qui est devenu aujourd'hui
secrétaire d'état aux affaires
européennes a nommé le besoin pour la
france de deux pour eux pour l'homme
l'union européenne de parler le langage
de la puissance donc début septembre
dans une interview sur lci
il parle de souveraineté européenne il
réaffirme la volonté macro nien d'une
souveraineté européenne est donc là on
voit émerger à travers son discours la
volonté de puissance de du couple
franco-allemand qui parle au nom de
l'ensemble de l'europe alors qu' il n'y
a pas d'unité en réalité et qui cherche
à diriger l'europe vers une forme de
souveraineté
il parle dans cette interview de
souveraineté militaire quand il parle
d'une armée il réactive le vieux serpent
de mer de l'armée européenne
il parle de souveraineté européenne de
frontières européennes et donc on voit
bien qu'on a un rapport de puissance et
une logique de puissance qui est
complètement différente
l'enjeu en biélorussie est où eh bien il
est de ramener la biélorussie vers
l'union européenne
on voit bien que le modèle qui est porté
par guirane of sky a c'est un modèle de
démocratie libérale façon europe de
l'ouest en tout cas c'est ce que
emmanuel macron anticiper c'est pour ça
qu'il prend fait et cause pour elle sans
chercher à apaiser le dialogue est donc
finalement à à trouver une voie médiane
entre loukachenko et ira dans ce cas y a
il prend fait et cause pour thierno sky
c'est à dire qu'il dit on va ramener la
biélorussie vers nous lorsque vladimir
poutine dit à loukachenko qui lui
assurera une sécurité militaire de
manière à ce que la paix et la
protection du peuple biélorusse soit
assurée je pense qu'il l'a dante est lui
aussi qu'il est possible de développer
un modèle politique qui ne soit pas
celui de l'europe de l'ouest
donc en fait c'est ça à mon avis dans la
relation de puissance qui se joue qui
est la clé est-ce que la biélorussie est
amené à intégrer l'union européenne ou
pas alors de personnes clés emmanuel
macron vladimir poutine
eugène berg le chef de l'état français
avait envisagé un cet été de se rendre
en russie pour rencontrer vladimir
poutine le revoir une visite reporté
aujourd'hui finalement peu évoqué un sur
le plan diplomatique ou est-ce qu'on en
est à propos du réchauffement des
relations entre paris
et moscou après est-ce que je peux
rebondir ce qu'a dit le prédécesseur
donc sur le nom parce que bon jeu mais
on n a pas on n'est pas là pour
polémiquer
à mon sens bon c'est peut-être sous
jacent mais je pense pas qu emmanuel
macron veut attirer la biélorussie dans
l'union européenne puisque déjà
souvenez vous en avril 2008 la géorgie
et l'ukraine c'est la france et
l'allemagne s'étaient opposés donc si on
se pose à la géorgie et à l'ukraine
on va s'opposer encore plus parce que la
biélorussie finalement il faut le voir
c'est une partie de la rue si je dirais
pas que c'est un pays quasiment
artificiel c'est un pays dont la langue
est très proche qui n'a jamais fait pas
vraiment été indépendante
l'identité est encore plus restreinte
que l'ukraine non le but
je crois que le président m'a kron a dit
je suis pour nouvelles élections parce
que je considère celle ci était quand
même trop trop entaché d'erreurs et
c'est au peuple biélorusse de décider
donc des élections une nouvelle
constitution et nouveau pouvoir
mais je ne pense pas qu'il ait eu la
naïveté où les dix ont l'outrecuidance
de dire on va la tirer à nous parce que
s'il dit ça alors là c'est une très
grave erreur
joe politique la russie ne peut pas
laisser la biélorussie comme à l'oral
soi-disant laissé l'ukraine
non là là il faut être très clair elle
avale et l'élargissement de l'otan elle
a avalé beaucoup de choses là c'est un
point de non retour et même beaucoup
d'américains luddisme je crois que là il
faut que ce soit clair
alors il aurait dépensé entre russes
voilà il nous reste quelques secondes
messieurs peut-être pour conclure l'un
après l'autre
un mot sur les relations franco russes
aujourd'hui en un mot jeune berg et puis
vous conclurez frédéric saint clair
alors bon le mot malheureusement
effectivement emmanuel macron devait
être à moscou le 9 mai pour le 75e
anniversaire de la victoire
il avait été critiqué pourquoi les à
moscou il voulait y aller
le la pandémie l'empêcher avant
évidemment la sphère navalni ils étaient
près dé à moscou vous savez il faut rien
exclure
si effectivement les tensions en baisse
ce qu'il faut j'ai un pack faut prier
dieu
ils sont très croyants nos amis russes
donc faute et prier dieu et par lénine
pour que ça s'apaise c'est peu probable
mais c'est pas tout à fait exclue vous
savez la vie internationale est pleine
d'imprévus et on verra et là
effectivement si ça s'apaise et bien
emmanuel macron pourra y aller
est-ce qu'il va parler au nom de leurs
apps ou pas bon s'il ya peu de chance
mais c'est pas totalement exclu et ce
serait finalement un scénario où il y
aurait une rencontre entre les deux
présidents l'un pas leur est évidemment
un peu au nom de l'europe
il faudrait qu'ils discutent qu'il
n'avait pas seul et donc dans les trois
mois où ou avant
c'est un scénario qu'il faut pas exclure
c'est à dario évidemment optimiste alors
je ne dirai pas que je le souhaite mais
j'espère encore qu'il n'est pas
totalement éliminés dans les mois à
venir et je crois qu'il faut et fondée
là dessus autrement on doit on arrive l
on doit conclure malheureusement on va
laisser le mot de la fin pour frédéric
que sinclair en quelques secondes s'il
vous plaît en quelques secondes je
maintiens je maintiens mon analyse je
pense que si emmanuel macron on
n'envisage pas une intégration stricto
sensu de la biélorussie en réalité ils
la considèrent potentiellement comme un
pivot géostratégique c'est à dire comme
le brésil ce qui les appeler certains
fument forme de satellites de l'union
européenne il cherche à étendre la la la
la puissance de l'union européenne sa
souveraineté et son influence et
raisonne en termes d'empyr 1 emmanuel
macron est donc globalement lempire
voisins c'est l' empire russe et donc de
ce fait là il faut qu'il y ait un
dialogue avec la russie mais ce dialogue
là ne se veut pas naïfs pour emmanuel
macron stains un rapport de puissance il
imagine qu'il va pouvoir rééquilibrer le
rapport de puissance entre l'union
européenne et la russie ce qui à mon
avis est une faute pour deux raisons la
première c'est qu'il n'y a pas de
souveraineté européenne et qu'il n'y en
aura pas puisque c'est une collection de
pays et la deuxième c'est parce que lors
la conception de la puissance européenne
est une puissance géoéconomique
uniquement n'est pas capable de faire
autre chose que de le placer des
sanctions économiques alors que la
conception de la puissance russe et
complète il ya une dimension économique
mais a aussi une dimension militaire
affirmé on l'a vu en ukraine
vous pourrez le voir ailleurs un grand
merci à tous les deux merci
jeune belge rappelle que vous êtes
ancien ambassadeur de france essayiste
merci à vous frédéric sinclair
éditorialiste ancien conseiller
politique de dominique de villepin